le couvre feu est il nécessaire dans
toutes les communes à brax en haute
garonne cette question tout le monde se
la pose depuis la mise en place de
nouvelles restrictions
et même si la commune de 2800 habitants
se trouve dans la métropole toulousaine
visés par les mesures gouvernementales
elle reste plutôt épargnée par
l'épidémie de coronavirus une
incompréhension renforcées par la
décision de la préfecture de
haute-garonne de ne pas élargir les
restrictions à la commune voisine de
léguevin une mise en application basée
sur le découpage administratif et qui
surprend alors que les deux communes
entretiennent des échanges quotidiens
je vais faire mes courses 1
au supermarché à côté j'ai mes enfants
qui sont scolarisés notamment le grand
au collège l'occurrence la pas pour
l'instant ce sont les vacances scolaires
mais voilà c'est notre quotidien on y va
et on comprends pas trop que ne soient
pas impactés quand aussi la taille du
village de broc ce qui est de 2800
habitants
et quand on voit côté des villages
voisins et amis qui ont ils sont quatre
fois plus importantes qui n'ont pas le
couvre feu c'est surprenant surprenant
de la façon dont on déterminer la zone
en couvre feu avec des conséquences
préjudiciables pour les commerçants les
restaurateurs de la commune sont obligés
d'annuler les nombreuses soirées prévues
dans les semaines à venir
des restrictions ciblées qui suscite
incompréhension et fatalisme depuis le
10 on peut plus rien faire j'ai rallumé
on va dire tous mes rendez vous avec le
diable pour pouvoir fermer à 20h est
rentré chez moi maintenant vu que je
dois de chez moi à maintenir quoi pour
quelle raison on n'en sait rien on n'a
pas plus de cas que d'autres communes
actuellement les leviers pas et lévignac
est pas pibrac y y et braque souci est
alors que pour nous il n'y a pas plus de
risques halleguen keita de kilomètres
que nous avons à brax comme dans
quarante deux autres communes de l'air
urbaine de toulouse
le couvre-feu doit être respecté entre
21h et 6h du matin au moins jusqu'à la
mi novembre